mich wieder das ehrlich gesagt an wenn
man gerade ältere Sportler hat also die
vielleicht 31 32 sind die schon so
unendlich viel Geld in ihrem Leben das
ist die Entscheidung unendlich viel Geld
Cristiano Ronaldo ist wahrscheinlich
Milliardär oder er ist Milliardär und er
sagt trotzdem hey ich nehme das noch mal
mit und es ist mir völlig egal was für
eine Liga ich spiele was das mit meinem
Ruf macht ob das meine Integrität als
Sportler und irgendeiner tangiert ich
nehme das Geld einfach mit und es ist
das gleiche bei Neymar es ist jetzt weil
was ist mit Jordan Anderson Johnson ist
für mich eines der tragischen Beispiele
einer der in seinen Liverpool Zeiten ein
Hoch geachteter Profi war der sich
extrem für die LG btq-rechte eingesetzt
hat einer der auch für Minderheiten im
Auge hatte der sich immer wieder durch
kluge Äußerung in die Schlagzeilen
gespielt hat und dann stellt man fest
der geht einfach er hat wahnsinnig viel
Kohle geboten bekommen und eiert jetzt
rum hat z.B auch zugelassen dass er auf
einem Bild einem Vorstellungsbild auf
dem er zu sehen war bei seinem neuen
clockt dass das schwarz-weiß
eingeblendet wurde damit man die
Regenbogen bin